project Veritas is suing James O'Keefe
and his new company and uh it's a crazy
story I think it's a death now for
project Veritas as an organization going
after James in this way but we do have
major breaking news related to this uh
we have right now uh apparently a
resignation letter from one of the
executives at Veritas I don't know if
this is related to the lawsuit against
James I believe it likely is
because I I have to say this is for
project Veritas to sue James is
basically them saying we are done we're
over and whatever Good Will whatever
good faith you know people may have had
in us after James left is completely
gone so we're going to go over that and
uh of course we have James here to talk
about that and more and then I I think
that'll be a heavy portion of this show
because we're gonna be getting into a
lot of that story with James here but we
do have other stories about Bud Light
being knocked off the top spot it is no
longer the number one beer in this
country Modelo is which in the United
States is not owned by Anheuser-Busch
internationally it is but here it's it's
constellation Brands they have all the
rights to it and then we have far left
is actually getting arrested this is
actually a very very big story the
Georgia Bureau of Investigation is
arresting people for fundraising on
behalf of these these activists these
well I should say extremists because
they're attacking government facility
the left says this is going after
legally protected speech and fundraising
efforts for illegal defense but I think
they're lying so we'll get into all that
before we get started my friends head
over to castbrew.com and pick up your
order of cast Brew Coffee it is our
company we're sponsoring ourselves if
you want to support the show buy our
product over at casper.com you can sign
up for the cast Brew Coffee Club get
three 12 ounce bags per month or just
come down here and pick whatever coffee
you like we've got rise with Roberto Jr
a light roast Appalachian nights a
robust dark roast and of course we have
Colombian and French rose with more to
come we're actually planning on
launching a signature Sheamus roast
that's right a shame is blunt for which
she will it'll be a deal we're doing a
Sheamus where he gets a portion of uh we
do a split thing on that so castbrew.com
to support the show and also go to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because one of a members only
uncensored show tonight and if you're a
member you get access to our Discord
server if you've been a member for at
least six months or you sign up at the
25 per month level you can submit
questions and actually call into our
uncensored show to ask us and our guests
questions so I recommend doing that
we're gonna have a really really good
after show I'm sure there's a lot to
talk about so smash that like button
right now subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends if you
think we do a good job joining us
tonight to talk about this of course is
the man himself Mr James O'Keefe you
might want to grab your microphone oh
there it is there it is usually my
microphones are tiny and hidden yeah
yeah this one is there's actually two
ones in the way all right sir everybody
knows who you are but uh how are you I'm
doing great A lot has happened since I
last saw you guys yeah yeah uh OMG no
more Veritas OMG so give us a quick
introduction to where you are now well I
started a company called OMG I got the
T-shirt I brought some swag for you too
oh very nice we'll put on the wall uh
OMG we break stories that make you go oh
my gosh righteous indignation it's a
it's a private company
subscription-based news organization I
started March 15th The Ides of March
it's been very successful and I it's a
private company I 100 own it and I'm
very excited about this Vision which is
to decentralize journalism because
people no longer Trust
institutions so we got to equip
thousands of people I've been talking
about doing this for many years Tim I've
talked about it with you yeah but I
think the time is now I think I'm ready
to go do it so that's what we're doing
right on and of course with the breaking
news it's good to have you here we can
we can talk about what's going on and uh
get to the bottom of it so thanks for
hanging out absolutely we got Sheamus
Coughlin of Freedom Tunes my name is
Sheamus I make cartoons I also make
podcasts so I have a podcast called
shamer that Arizona rumble on Tuesdays
and Thursdays I also uh have the
cartoons Tim mentioned those are over at
Freedom Tunes we're going to be
releasing a funny video tomorrow we were
going to be releasing a debunkers video
today but unfortunately there were some
complications so we're going to be
releasing that one in this next week but
I think you guys are really going to
enjoy it and I think you're going to
like tomorrow's cartoon as well hi
everyone Ian Crossland here happy to be
here James good to see you my man great
to see you it's been what a year and a
half or something like that well we'll
talk more I want to get down to down to
the bottom of this all right answers.com
it's a pleasure to meet you James and uh
excited for tonight's episode so let's
get started guys we actually have a
couple big stories related to this but I
think we'll just start before the the
the breaking story we have it's a
resignation of an executive I think
we'll get into that but we need to give
context first so the first segment we
have from timcast.com James O'Keefe and
Media Group sued by project Veritas
action and action committee the project
Veritas founder allegedly ran a muck put
his own interests ahead of the outlet
former CEO and founder of project
Veritas James O'Keefe has been sued by
his former Outlet O'Keefe Media Group
and two former employees of project
Veritas RC Maxwell and Anthony
iotropolis am I pronouncing that right
you tropical blue so yeah are also
included in the lawsuit for allegedly
breaching their contracts for the
benefit of OMG they say O'Keefe
allegedly ran a muck and put his own
interest out of veritas which asserted
the outlets founder failed in his duties
and caused serious and significant
damage according to the lawsuit which
includes project Veritas Action Group as
a plaintiff the lawsuit note lawsuit
notes O'Keefe was suspended but not
removed as a member from his former role
in Project Veritas as CEO and president
of project Veritas action fondant on
February 6. so I want to just uh
simplify this they're saying that uh
James you in the lawsuit you have no
right to start a company you have no
right to do the work you've you've done
and this was the shocking thing to me
the work that you have historically done
before Veritas during Veritas and now
after they say is proprietary to project
Veritas so so what what's going on in
your words oh
um how's life how's life that's a that's
a macro question
um make it take a couple minutes to just
say a few things oh yeah grab that
microphone monologue monologue it maybe
there you go um let me just tell you a
story how about that and I'll answer the
answer to your question uh I've been
doing this for
about 15 years I started in college so I
guess that's probably more like 20 years
but in a major way 15 years along the
way I have been
you know there's been a lot of arrows
sent my way and at my team
because when you're the tip of the spear
you just get a lot of flack right I
think we all know that and then maybe
these days it's directly proportional to
the amount of flack you get but
I mean I have been um I've way back when
I I received a letter from Planned
Parenthood threatening to jail me for
working with Lila in California because
the statute 632 the penal code
um I did the acorn story with Andrew
Breitbart Hannah Giles they sued me for
recording in Maryland
um I had to raise money to pay lawyers I
was arrested by the FBI in January of
uh falsely accused
uh they said I entered under under false
pretense even though I showed my ID I
spent three years on federal probation
and it is while I was on federal
probation that I founded project eratos
in a in a garage with with like no money
credit card debt negative equity
it was Against All Odds
uh and while on federal probation
starting that company I was sent
criminal grand jury subpoenas by the
state of New Hampshire in 2011 2012 for
expose New Hampshire
um I was sued countless times for
defamation
uh including one by Shirley Teeter I won
that in federal district court at Jury
verdict and nobody reported on it
um I mean I could go on and on with the
amount of flack and arrows that my
colleagues and I have taken
there was one story where I was chased
on the Highway by a teacher's Union
official in New Jersey chased down the
highway so now now they run away from me
but back then they ran they they
followed me on on Interstate 80 in uh in
New Jersey Alyssa plachnick was her name
and all the defamation that almost makes
you want to just say I can't I can't do
this anymore particularly if you're sane
and rational
and I could go on you know and I don't
say I don't say these things to to come
across like I'm a victim that's not what
I'm getting at I I love what I do I'm
passionate about it I say it because of
the human aspects of it
um it's different it's different when
you're taking on all these arrows it
hits differently
when the arrows come from the people
that are ostensibly supposed to be your
allies I've taken a lot of arrows I
never thought I'd be taking them in the
back
it just feels different
um there's a great article by by Dr
Malone which I want to talk about with
you we'll talk about that later but um
um I want to say that I have I agree
with you Tim that I feel untethered I
think you said this back and I think it
was March or April yeah I feel free
you know after jobs was fired from Apple
he said yeah I actually won the most
creative periods of my life I I didn't
have the weights that that you know
buried me down in many ways this is a
blessing so I feel liberated I'm very
excited about what I'm doing I'm I've
got a Thousand Eleven Hundred people on
a CRM citizen journalists around the
country wow and I'm dispatching them
um that's something that I wasn't doing
previously
so I'm very I'm very inspired I'm very
hopeful and I and I've decided to kind
of take the high road here I I I I think
I need to do that for myself
um this is I'm still going through this
whatever this is and I'm learning about
human nature and of all the things I've
learned I probably learned most of
mostly about like board maintenance I
didn't really you know most people don't
realize 501c3s are run by Boards they're
not owned by anybody and that creates
its own issues
um and I never really paid attention
to to to that part of it I I ran project
Veritas like I was the owner even though
I wasn't I took responsibility for
everything so it's difficult to watch
your own
creation and lifeblood
attack you
um
and I've and I've moved on because
that's what I've been asked to do
so it's it's we're in a very strange
situation in space and time right now
and there's a lot to unpack but that's
that's in a nutshell Where We Are
so what's up with this uh when did you
learn in the lawsuit I mean this is
dropped today right I learned because
will Sumner The Daily Beast called my
phone and whenever will Sumner from The
Daily Beast calls you it's usually not
hey gave them your number hey everyone's
got my phone number
yeah that's when I learned of it oh wow
wow so uh well do you uh do you wanna do
you have I don't know if you can
actually say anything I mean the obvious
thing is when you're being sued you just
don't talk about it because you've got
to say it in court well that's the the
process is the punishment right so I was
I was rated by the FBI
uh in September November 2021 and the
process is the punishment because and I
talked about it
and but but that's the thing the lawyers
say don't talk about it yep and I have
to make executive decisions about what I
can and should say and that's that's
what this whole thing is designed to do
it's designed to shut me down and
silence me it's not the first time this
I've been through this so I I uh I I
went through the lawsuit a little bit
and I have it here
um I have it pulled up actually and
their relief let me let me show you the
prayer for Relief this is what project
Veritas is asking of the Court it says
declare O'Keefe and breach of his
employment agreement in violation of his
fiduciary duties and in violation of his
duty of loyalty declare eotropolis in
breach of what's up do you want me to
bring this up yeah yeah okay cool uh
declarity atropolis and breach of the
atropolis agreement declare Maxwell and
breach of the Maxwell agreement declare
OMG to have tortiously interfered with
the employment agreement the atropolis
agreement the Maxwell agreement to
Claire O'Keefe to have misappropriated
plaintiff's Trade Secrets that's big
right there declare O'Keefe liable to
identify plaintiff for the cost of
defense and or liabilities arising from
actions taken by him or his errors or
omissions issue a preliminary and
permanent enjoy Junction and joining
O'Keefe and OMG from soliciting or
contacting plaintiff's donors employees
or contractors disparaging plaintiffs
obtaining using or disclosing
plaintiff's confidential information and
keeping and failing to return
plaintiff's property now some of these
things like I understand like you got to
give the property back if you have any
whatever that may be about but the uh
there's some things here that are the
trade secrets
what what you need to understand in this
is here's I I you can respond if you if
you can or want to the way I see it
you started James you started project
Veritas you brought Trade Secrets
they then it it seems like an
Institutional capture with one of these
guys on the board apparently having
pronouns in his bio or something all of
a sudden they're telling you you're
locked up you're suspended stop doing
your work so you go off and do your own
thing and then they say nope we own
those the everything that you built we
own every technique all the methodology
those are ours and you can never use
them again that effectively says the
methods of James O'Keefe can never be
used by James Oakey right then and and
the money that was raised and that I
raised taking lots of black cars around
to raise it and if you get the inside
joke there but uh they say there's black
cars or inappropriate
um was raised to expose corruption and
now is being used in an effort to stifle
my efforts to expose corruption I want
to add to this how does that work the
the black cars thing they say that you
black cars you drive around in these
like uh SUVs or whatever you get that
are very expensive I'll tell you guys a
story we were at we did an event in New
York and we had very serious security
threats we had security running around
the building looking for individuals who
uh we we believe were involved in very
serious threats and swatting and things
like that so when the event wraps and
they're like here's your exit Mr pool
I'm like yo there's like a hundred
people out there and we're under like
tight security conditions so I need to
like get out James Ike James says I have
a vehicle for this reason come with me
and then James brings me into an SUV
there's a reason why you have vehicles
like this to use that against you when
you are the target of threats death
threats
like ridiculous law enforcement rates I
mean
who's funding this
what money are they using to pay for
this is it 51c3 money I mean donors who
gave to Veritas are paying them to sue
you they're right I mean bear with me
for a minute it's going to take about 90
seconds I want to read something to you
you know Dr Malone the guy who did the
stories about covid and very smart
fantastic very smart guy very you know
Robert Malone I become pretty close to
him recently I was having dinner with
him but he wrote this a few months ago I
just want you to listen just bear with
me for two minutes
um remember that story about Pfizer with
the cage fight this happened a few days
after that these are Malone's words and
I just want to read them before you're
on this is profound he wrote this on
like a sub stack or something
um without knowing the details of all
this
this episode has all the earmarks of a
terrible institutional problem in
non-profits that we've seen many times
before all it takes is a remarkable
success big infusion of money a weak
jealous confused board using disgruntled
employees as Shields the board develops
a backwards looking Focus taking apart
the success why did management take
those risks why did the head of the
organization not consult with us why
didn't the head of the organization
follow industry established practices
how come the organization's president
did not do something different than what
he did to establish long-term success
which is a word that they use long-term
success
I remember this one one time I raised a
million dollars and they said well you
could have raised 10 million if you did
something differently I was like what
why did they do it above all why is this
guy getting all the attention
other insiders in the company start
Consulting with the board and the plot
is hatched all it takes is an
investigation some claimed guy at the
top is making everyone work too hard and
then people get burned out you can fill
in the blanks with complaints and
there's always something somewhere the
scheme usually involves claims of
financial nonsense such as office
parties or helicopter rides once the
decision is made the oust the guy he
really has no chance
All That Remains is the need to find a
pretext next thing you know next thing
you know the unthinkable happens
the hardest working Innovative and most
effective person is out the board keeps
the money the disgruntled staff gets
their pound of Flesh and everyone who
stabbed the guy in the back gets a raise
and life goes on I've seen this many
times before non-profits that kill the
goose that lays the golden egg the
achievements gradually die the
organization maintains some name
recognition and they become a letterhead
this is the Triumph of bureaucracy over
achievement I had found I had a Founder
tell me
that it's actually a fight against
Excellence itself that was it took me a
while to understand what he meant by
that it's a tragedy but unfortunately
very common particularly at hospitals
and churches and part of the problem
traces to the structure of non-profits
they're not owned by anybody so there's
a committee whose job is to hire and
fire the CEO but they're not meant to
manage the company
they're not meant to manage the company
they're supposed to put a leader in
charge because you can't lead by
committee that's stalinesque
the board hires the president president
hires and fires a staff the board is
unpaid which usually means they have no
reason to be involved in the operations
in the first place but all the while
they have a sense that they should be
controlling things even though they
really understand what's going on so
that was Malone
uh who's spot on spot on the the looking
backwards thing's brilliant they they
attacked all the things that you were
doing without pointing out Veritas is
extremely successful
because of the things you have done and
continue to do
they stop it in this single moment out
of the entire context of the the life of
veritas and say look at these things he
just did
instead of saying look at the things the
similar things he's been doing that have
led to Our Success
so they can make it seem like Veritas
was always where it was and only now are
these things causing problems well the
moment of greatest achievement often
carries the greatest risk and it's it's
a it's a cliche right you know you get
the Flack if you're over the target yeah
but what I've realized I was just doing
a Twitter space is downstairs
um is there's a lot of evil
in the world
um I think the evil is getting more evil
but there's also a lot of good and I I
saw a lot of I mean is a blessing
because I was overtaken by a sense of
gratitude for all the really good people
that were around me and I was overtaken
with a sense of gratitude to see who
people really are
and and and you need to be very strong
if you're going to do this again another
cliche we think we know what that means
you don't know what that means until
you've been rated
um until you've been uh targeted and
attacked and sued and defamed and and
the more effective you are at your
mission
the more those people are going to do
that to the people around you so you
better surround yourself with really
strong humans who can withstand
blistering attacks whether they're true
or not doesn't matter
um these are these are this is kind of a
allegory for I think what we're going
through in the country right now I think
this is sort of where we are it feels
like Veritas was captured
yeah and it seems like the purpose of
this suit and everything they've done
has been to stop and to silence you well
I I've moved on I've
started a new deal I I'm we just posted
the RFK podcast which is really great
um I don't know if you've seen that just
posted today we talk about fear his
uncle JFK I've got reporters as I speak
undercover everywhere I'm I'm trying to
do my my job I'm focused on the future
and I you know the the forward-looking
glass of a car is bigger than your rear
view mirror but this this is why it
seems to me ideological because you've
moved on well and and look look after
you leave Veritas everybody says James
O'Keefe is Veritas people are very
critical of project Veritas donors came
out in your defense all everyone and and
veritas could their leadership they
could have come out and said
fine
look guys we want to keep doing good
work we wish James the best
you know you may not be happy with how
things went but we're gonna try and make
two good things out of this instead of
just a fight the fact that they've gone
after you this this says to me it is
more about ideology because if Veritas
was truly trying to do good work they
would realize that this lawsuit is
basically a stake in the heart of
veritas what little was left that people
believed in with project vertas is now
completely gone because they're
attacking you yeah exactly I mean if
there are issues with what you were
doing were truly the things that they
claimed they were when they ousted you
they should have no problem with you
going and doing your own thing I I got
the feeling that it was personal like I
wasn't around you when you were going
through it but like I imagine you were
high stress and you were just like I
don't know if you were lashing out of
people or like just like making demands
and then they were like we've had enough
of them we can't take them anymore and
then they just but like are you still on
contract with Veritas no I was fired on
February 10th so they say they never
fired you
I say they did
and our lawyers say they did February
10th because if you're saying if you're
still on contract then there are clauses
usually in bylaws for 501c3s where the
board has to agree that you can make
private uh profit off of the anything
related to the the foundation but if
you're not on contract with them that's
another story I think I'm not a lawyer
but I would that's what I would surmise
well I wanna we've got breaking news
ladies and gentlemen in relation to this
so we received a message from April Moss
she is a CBS Detroit whistleblower a
meteorologist whose story became public
in June of 2021
she says that she's obtained an
exclusive copy of a resignation letter
from Dan Strack of project Veritas and
that she stands by James O'Keefe
currently working on the story and uh
there is some personal information so
I'm not going to show the email but I do
have it it says today I sent the
following email to the board of
directors and Leadership project Veritas
board of directors please take this
email as notification of my resignation
as executive director of project Veritas
and project project Veritas action I am
honored to have worked alongside some of
the most dedicated and driven people
I've ever met I promise I gave it my all
I want you to know how much in the past
15 months have meant to me to work with
and for you all has been incredible the
past four months have been the biggest
challenge I suspect most of us have ever
faced at least in our professional
careers it is important to me that you
know I tried my best I know you did as
well I am sorry if I let you down why
now it's complicated the truth is that I
no longer know how to help I will never
forget any of you you are amazing the
world needs you take care of each other
if I can if I can ever be helpful to you
at all please reach out I hope our paths
cross again and that's uh Dan's track so
you know him obviously yes he he worked
for Goldman Sachs and he was the
executive director
that I hired uh in 2022. 2022 so he's so
uh I don't do anything about it he's
resigning I mean this is related that's
news to me and uh uh
would you tell me what you think I mean
I I don't know if this uh uh so we're
receiving it from another reporter on
whistleblower well April was was a
whistleblower for CBS News she was
whistleblower like two years ago she was
a meteorologist and she went live on the
air and said she's going to expose her
own network so so she's gone on to do
other reporting we've not received
confirmation from Project Veritas that
he has resigned so other than that I
don't know if you can say it's confirmed
or whether or not we know for sure that
he's actually resigned but it seems
plausible at the very least I try to be
a bit more careful on these things right
I'd rather have a statement from Project
Veritas confirming yes he did resign
right it was so I'd have to see what
April is there is there a picture or
something or uh there's there's a
screenshot of the resignation email
looks like from someone's very dirty
laptop yeah and then she just says she
has obtained an exclusive copy of
resignation letter uh from dance that's
true then Dan's resigned
I mean the the number two guy at PV is
is out I don't know when but um I don't
know when he's interesting timing it's
it's interesting timing I think it may
be related to the lawsuit I mean the
role of a the role of a board and a
non-profit is to hire and fire the CEO
which is what a board should do what a
board should not do is run the company
you can't you can't leave by committee
it doesn't work
um so that's very interesting timing and
there's obviously more to the story
there I think his resignation is is
probably related to the lawsuit and I
have to imagine it it look if you work
for Veritas especially as Veritas is
suing James O'Keefe I mean your career
is going to get nuked where are you
gonna go everyone in the media has lied
about you and called you propaganda fake
news and everything so you're not going
to CNN
now Veritas is attacking its its founder
who is beloved by the community so
you're basically saying if you keep
working there well they need there needs
to be there needs to be a leader like
people people there needs to be a person
like from my understanding of companies
is that again if there's a board they
hire and fire the guy at the top so the
question is who's in charge you can't
you know a board doesn't run a board
doesn't run a company a board appoints
the person that runs the company there's
nobody running it now but there has to
be there has to be so so you know are we
are we are we taking issue with the
reality that there needs to be someone
at the top is that the issue because
whoever whoever it is they're going to
be faced with the same dilemma that I
had I mean I I was you know
I have to raise a lot of money let me go
back to this like I have to pay lawyers
to defend myself with this deal I'm not
I'm not a wealthy man
um for what I was Raising 20 25 million
a year that's a hundred thousand a day a
hundred that's if you're working a
14-hour day you know that that's that's
thousands of thousands of dollars an
hour so if I if I have to get from point
A to point B yeah I'm gonna get an SUV
because I'm on the phone with sources
well with my other phone on the on the
phone with a donor while with my toe on
the phone with an employee while typing
on my laptop because that's what I do
and and you know you need someone who's
gonna walk through walls and and by the
way what is true
and this is a mistake I will admit a
fault of mine on Monday morning I don't
ask how your weekend was
I don't say how was your Thanksgiving I
probably I probably did that twice
should a good leader ask you about that
probably
but I'm so busy trying to raise money
for all these freaking lawyers
to defend myself from all these lawsuits
because everyone wants me to fight back
and stand and stand on principle and
stand on truth
and not bend over and take it and settle
so there's a price there's a price to
pay
to not bending over do you do you think
it was a mistake starting Veritas as a
non-profit I don't regret anything in my
life because everything that I have been
through has taught me so much in many
ways this is not a a new story there's
nothing new Under the Sun but in many
ways this is a new story
we're like no one's ever gotten this far
in the video game
I mean I'm happy that I went through
what I went through
um because I had at the time you know I
had to go through that it was like
I was in a garage
in a 300 square foot like halfway house
looking piece of garage with
negative equity and I'm like well I
gotta make the video but in order to
make the video I gotta buy a microphone
in order to buy the microphone I gotta
go get money in order to get money I
gotta raise money okay I put the video
out okay now I'm being threatened with
lawsuits I gotta raise my mind to pay
lawyers so what vehicle do I need to get
to get the money to raise okay I get
into five one c three okay to get a five
one three three I need a board let me
get the board it was like you know it
was a means to an end yeah and you know
the way the way I see it now is
it's remarkable to see that over the
span of what 13 years you uh 12 and a
half 13 years you build up to to the
point of 25 million dollars a year 7
million on lawyers seven mil on lawyers
on average every year or whatever last
year five it was it was in the last few
years four and a half five seven seven
million we file public tax returns so
it's all public information at 990 tax
return 7 million I had lawyers making
over a million a year
which is double my salary you can look
that up apparently some lawyers are
still making some money off of projects
and I and I got to raise money to to
defend myself here with the processes
the punishment how are you gonna how are
you gonna raise half a million bucks
people say how do you do that if you go
to my telegram page you can there's a
link there's a C4 that we have I'm on
the board I'll tweet it you can donate
but Tim I could write 30 War Stories I
was in court last September in DC
federal court Civil Trial they sued me
for breach of fiduciary duty trespass
and some other things jury trials
democracy Partners Bob creamer was that
was the video inside violence I was in a
sensory deprivation chamber AKA a
federal courtroom for like a week and a
half in Washington DC which is its own
hell hole because when you're in DC for
24 hours it's like a spiritual attack
against you yeah and there's there's a
jury and there's all these lawyers and
I'm and I'm on the witness stand
and I'm and I and I could have probably
settled the lawsuit I don't know for uh
you know something a couple hundred
grand maybe 100 Grand but I chose to do
that what I thought was the right thing
and not settle it and go to the Supreme
Court if I had to Millions yeah over a
million dollars spent it was the right
thing to do
but to do that you have to you have to
walk through walls you have to you have
to do things that people don't want to
do like my Michael Jordan said you know
leadership as a price yeah and victory
has a price
and and you know are we willing to pay
it
you want you know why um
news like what you do is so fleeting I
mean I think you do but for the audience
the rhetorical you
I've told the story before because I've
I've encountered this literally talking
to heads of media
you get a guy who comes into uh uh you
get a journalist or a media guy and he
goes to the investors and says I wanna
to do this investigative reporting and
expose corporate and governmental
malfeasance I need investment Capital to
get started and the Venture capitalists
and the business guys go awesome
fantastic that sounds really really good
so uh what's our return you say well you
know this kind of news does really
really well millions of views 10 million
views 20 million views it's amazing and
we can sign up people to be members
support our work so you know we could be
looking at a very lucrative Enterprise
and say yeah but time timeline wise when
are you gonna get the story what's
When's the first big scoop right and you
say well I don't know we have to do the
investigation and they say how much does
that cost that's going to cost 300 000
for the preliminary investigation and
they say and how much do I get back from
that well we don't know we're
investigating a story we have no
guarantee the story pans out the way we
think it's going to that's right and
they say I am not going to invest
millions of dollars or even 300 000
unless you tell me when I get my money
back then someone else walks in the room
and says don't listen to that guy I'm
gonna launch a news company and I'm
gonna get you a two million dollar
return in three years and they go oh wow
how you gonna do it we're going to
publish click bait garbage nonsense and
complain about people's politics because
you you worked for vice right that's
right Shane Smith yep it's funny Shane
Smith my executive assistant's name is
Shane Smith with it why not any and
vice's uh unique value proposition was
we go there I think I saw a billboard in
New York Times we or Times Square we go
there yeah something like that so their
unique value proposition was they
actually go on the location they're
reporting on and then around
2014-15 is when things started to shift
and they said you know and then they
started relying presumably this is my
opinion more on ridiculous clickbait
because so this is a really important
Point investigative reporting is like
outrageously expensive like beyond what
people can fathom because even sending
people like flights hotels you know you
know it didn't cost a lot more nowadays
lawsuits I mean we're talking you're
right hundreds of thousands of dollars
do one story so if you're a businessman
if you're if you're a venture capitalist
and you want to make a profit on this
good luck
good luck to you you know what our
budget was for uh a three-day shoot we
got a story boom breaking there's a
there's there's civil unrest happening
in this country the president Megan
ousted we're sending a crew down 50
Grand
it's a bigger story it's going to take a
week or two weekends 100 200 Grand and
that was cheap
you've got salaries camera equipment
travel you need you got to have
insurance on a 30 000 camera not to
mention lawsuits legal you got people
who are going to be detained entering
the country you got people who are going
to be pulled out by cops because they're
covering the stuff you've got four
people have to go there you've got
security requirements you've got
security briefings you've got Health if
you're going to Egypt you got to go in
for all these different vaccines you you
if you're a businessman and your purpose
is in the 90s I wrote a book about this
called American muckraker in the 50s 60s
and 70s there was Integrity there were
bosses with what I call balls maybe you
prefer huevos or testicular fortitude
whatever huevos eggs balls bosses with
balls okay I'm just gonna say balls
people in the comments be like well I
don't have balls I'm a woman okay
whatever what's a woman
2023 whatever people had balls they
would say you know what I'm you know the
cigar and the Fedora I'm gonna spend
that money because it's the right thing
to do it's the right thing to do doing
the right thing is expensive it comes at
a cost but it comes at a human cost but
it was also to a certain degree vanity
to a certain degree because you had
people running these institutions saying
we're going to be the best news
organization that's ever been and that
means going there that means going there
and we can we can but my philosophy was
always since day one day one my core
value my tenant was whatever it does
cost I will get that money to do that
thing
so that was my that was my my rason
Detra was I'm gonna go do this project
or I'm gonna have I'm gonna go get the
story if it cost me 1.4 million to get
it I'll find a way to get the money so
that I can do the thing now it's let's
get the money forget the thing let's
focus on the pursuit of that thing over
there journalism is anathema to the
commercial imperatives yes and unit I
think happens with let's just say insert
hypothetical media non-profit after a
certain amount of years people get
involved and they start saying hey we're
making 25 million dollars a year that
story is a little bit risky I kind of
like the way things are going that's big
money now I never thought of it that way
because I work my I I work so hard I
mean I I worked so hard to to raise that
and I never celebrated I never celebrate
getting a check I only celebrate getting
the story and if someone on my team says
you gotta check for 100 grand I said no
we celebrate when we get the stuff when
we publish the story that's when we
celebrate
but yeah I mean I guess you could think
about it and you look at the numbers and
go wow that's some big money well I can
I can do that I can I can do that hell
with that guy he doesn't know anything
he doesn't work in private Equity he
does not manage me he's not even gonna
Harvard MBA I'm gonna go in there and do
that I I bet it's it it's it's it was
very painful
um but it was necessary for me to get to
the next evolution of what I'm about to
do I would be willing to bet
that the near absolute majority of
people who have given to project Veritas
if they heard a story about James
O'Keefe boarding a private jet to fly
down for a vacation in Miami Beach with
a nice suit and sunglasses they'd be
laughing and clapping being like this is
exactly what the man deserves it this is
Success this is Victory if someone like
James O'Keefe can live in style with the
work that he does we're on the right
track so the idea that you simply
driving in a car was somehow offensive
or detrimental to the organization is is
laughable to me what I was saying before
is
look if you launched a private company
and from the get-go and you brought in
members and you ran it as a membership
you know uh like like you're doing now
with OMG
you you'd post a picture of yourself top
G getting on a private jet with a
Bugatti or whatever and people would be
going like yes like not only are we
winning but James is flaunting his
success to show all of the corruption
and to inspire young people that there's
a path of success
Elon Musk says the private
transportation is the one thing that can
maximize your time because you can have
two meetings in or three meetings in a
day like there was one oh absolutely
woke up in New York at a meeting I went
to Wisconsin at a meeting and I had
Arizona I had three meetings in one day
and you're you're running a company you
have to you know you're you're raising
spending a hundred thousand a day your
time this is basic economics it is so
valuable that it it becomes imperative
for you to get from this point to this
point obviously everyone knows that but
Tim we did a story on OMG speaking of a
new company we did a story on um at the
FEC we knocked on doors and you know we
just knocked on doors it it it's it was
expensive we had to go to Maryland we
gotta go here we gotta go there but now
citizens are knocking on doors they're
inspired they're running around the
country what can I do it's it's a
fraction of the budget of these media
corporations and we're still getting
results so this is what people need to
realize
the path to luxury wealth Comfort High
Society has typically been for a long
time garbage it has been people going on
TV with big fake butts in and that's
fine if you like it I got no beef
but I've always asked myself how come
firefighters don't get paid more money
oh it's like oh we can't put it in the
budget we can't but police salaries are
super low the the the these leftists
want to abolish the police they complain
about cops like well cops don't get paid
very well it's not a job people want to
do and feel good and safe doing it's
high risk yet
Sports play athletes celebrities get
paid ridiculous amounts of money and the
person who is in a movie posts a video
of themself boarding a private jet with
a you know fancy Dom Perignon or
something and everyone says if I want to
succeed and have wealth and luxury you
have to be a vapid pop culture sales
there's a lot more here that I could say
that I'm not going to because I really
sorry there's a lot more here
I I don't want to get into the um
there's some things I could tell you
that would like make you go what but I
don't
I don't want to be goaded into going
there because I think that's what the in
the intent is here to try to get me to
do but there's there was something about
like you know people should be making
the same money or there shouldn't be a
disparity of of you know you know the
CEO shouldn't be you know having a
different form of security versus this
old guy here well well this guy's
getting attacked and his life's
threatened so you do we want to get paid
equally so some of this doesn't make a
lot a lot of actual sense
um and um
institutional capture I mean the
southern district of New York the
southern district of New York is where
the FBI rated me so now I'm being sued
in the sdny
a jury trial
in order to issue an injunction against
me to stop
exposing corruption
um by the organization that I founded
which is which mission is the state of
mission is to expose corruption
and they've issued a injunction to stop
the founder from exposing corruption
they have issued an injunction or I'm
sorry they issued a file a lawsuit to to
request the federal courts to to stop
um investigative reporting like I always
say like you brought this stuff to
Netflix they would like laugh at you
like this is crazy
um but just another day in my life just
to wrap up my last point we should be
happy to see the James
relaxing on a private jet we should be
like you do good work you stand up for
something honorable you help this
country you get rewarded for doing it
instead and I don't I just mean I don't
mean to just put this on you it's
something everybody everybody is in
their mind that if you're going to do
non-profit work you should be poor and
I'm not literally every single person
but I used to do non-profit fundraising
and I have to explain to people they're
like did you hear the CEO that nonprofit
gets paid a million dollars and I was
like good wow which which non-profit I
didn't know you did that oh I worked I
did fundraising for a whole bunch uh I
did I did fundraising for Greenpeace I
worked for the perk groups I worked oh
that's right a handful of others some of
those are 51c4s yeah seven cameras there
he actually saw you working you would be
super is actually a good place to
probably have some I think you're right
Tim I think I think there's nothing
wrong with taking a helicopter I mean
taking a helicopter home I I know I know
people who do that I won't name them but
that's that's a standard industry
practice if you're a 20 30 40 50 million
dollar company you get home so you can
get a good night's sleep so you can wake
up fresh and go to work and go to
meetings and go travel but they're it's
just part of it's just part of business
I think the issue is that people look at
things like hopping on a private jet or
a private car as luxury instead of
necessity well what is the root of all
socialism what is the socialism Envy
yeah Envy what is socialism really about
it's about Envy oh it's not it's about
hating the guy who's achieving something
and successful tearing him down when in
reality what we should be doing is
lifting everybody up but my point is
this it's it's misplaced too so I get a
request like hey Tim we want you to fly
out here and come on this show and I'm
like okay I only fly first class that's
not because I'm like I deserve exactly
it's because okay I'm going to 16 hours
today I can catch a red eye after work
but I gotta go to bed I'll sleep on the
plane which barely works and I wake up
feeling like crap but I'm willing to do
that sounds like it sounds like Envy to
me yeah that's an Envy thing which has
no place in in a uh in in strategy or or
or corporate governance or anything like
that that that's that's an emotional uh
thing well tell us about OMG now OMG has
been very successful
um Got my swag here uh OMG O'Keefe Media
Group so that when they type in OMG it
can't be censored because it's a
commonly used acronym on social media
that's brilliant
um and it and what this is a very
ambitious Vision
um which is to effectively create
Uber for journalism so instead of just
everyone being on my payroll I want to
equip everyone to go do what I do so
everyone oh so I get you know hundreds
of messages a day please investigate the
school board in Utah I had a lot of
Canadians message me today that was
interesting
um and what we want to do is equip them
give them cameras and to go have them go
do this and open source my knowledge so
everything I've learned about what I do
I'm producing a series of master classes
on ethics law technology and I'm
teaching people how to do this because I
think it does require some skills it
requires being being trained and
educated and I'm going to open source
that I'm going to put it behind a
paywall O'Keefe mediagroup.com you can
subscribe it's twenty dollars a month
and you can get access to this
information we have a database of like
1100 people and we're deploying them
um and we're doing as I speak they're in
the field recording follow-ups on Pfizer
the FDA the government the Deep State
the administrative State the three
letter agencies school boards teachers
media companies
um we want to help everyone but when
people say hey James can you please go
do this story now I'm saying no you go
do that story
it's on you I'll give you a camera I'll
ship the 500 camera I'll teach you but
you gotta figure it out because I can't
do it all myself it's not sustainable
one of our biggest stories is is now
getting Congress to act this is the um
act blue uh donations that were being
funneled into individuals with like 10
000 donations on their name and things
like that that's crazy how did you find
out about that that was found out by a
citizen journalist in in Wisconsin
election watch Peter is his name and he
just went on the web FCC website he's
like well that's odd this one guy he's a
modest guy in Annapolis has got made
like 10 000 donations and I just went to
knock on his door
and and they said well I'd like to
donate that many times but I didn't yeah
so so it's leading to congressional
action now yeah right on I mean imagine
if the rest of the media actually did
that and followed those leads instead of
publishing articles on why Star Trek was
racist
but that's the thing writing writing an
article about Star Trek being racist
clicks super easy money yep and and
what's happening is this kind of of
media is becoming dominant and then it
results in
surface level understanding of the world
hyperpolarization and people focusing on
things that are substantially less
important you get YouTube channels where
they're like we're gonna make our 160th
video about Dave Rubin and I'm like but
Dave rubin's a guy on YouTube like you
could talk about the president uh you
know uh I think we talked about David
Pacman and I unfairly criticize him for
talking about Trump so much and now I
realize no that's actually fine like if
you're going to talk about the president
a thousand times I totally get it you're
right you should if you're going to talk
about AOC if you're going to talk about
people in positions of power and
authority heads of Industry that I
understand if you're going to claim that
a YouTuber who ranks at like number one
thousand no that's just that's just
vapid e drama but it's easy to make it
Riles people up at the lowest common
denominator it makes money and it's very
difficult to do the research people want
to hear their opinion being uttered by
somebody else but that doesn't actually
change anything thing I mean why don't
journalists do this my theory is they
don't do it because if you actually
point a camcorder or a hidden camera in
any direction in a bureau or a
government office it'll contradict what
you see on television yeah like reality
contradicts narrative and the other
thing is I I think I think I've always
said that we hold a mirror up to people
and they don't like what it is that they
see they they hate the person who holds
the mirror up to them so I mean going
back to the citizen journalist thing we
had we had people that are so humbled
that we reached out to them as Texas
people I was speaking to there's a group
of people exposing something local in
Texas and she was shocked that OMG that
James O'Keefe would would send her a
camera like well you're going after like
Pfizer and the Pentagon and the Deep
state so why would you talk to us it's
like well you've got to start local
gotta go to your local school board
meeting right but Tim you were
downstairs with me and I was on the
Twitter spaces and and someone said well
I don't know where to start and I said
have you gone to your school board
meeting yet she said no I didn't know I
could don't doesn't I don't have to have
a kid school is like no you're a
taxpayer go to your school board meeting
yeah put on these little cameras and
talk to people in the hallway and see
what you come up with so we're starting
there do you hire them or do you uh have
them as contractors or do you just send
them stuff to get started we have a form
on our website O'Keefe needigroup.com
you click on the link and there's a
citizen journalist request form and we
just ship them a camera provided they're
not
um
insane or stupid
insane or stupid uh we'll send you a
camera and uh you know you'll have to
maybe perhaps sign a waiver
um and then we'll pay you we had we had
a young woman in Minnesota record her uh
official in college
saying shh don't we transgender person
will be in your room as your roommate
but we won't tell you that they're
transgender saying this to to her and
she recorded it wow and and we paid her
a thousand bucks for the footage for the
footage okay well I think that's a very
important Mission because you're putting
a lot of emphasis on what's happening at
the local level and it's good to focus
on National politics obviously everyone
in this room does that but for
individual people in any given Community
to be involved with their school board
and then also be able to see like
undercover journalism on what's going on
at their school board I think is
incredibly valuable
I think so too it's so necessary dude
all I want is because I'm a big fan of
Barrett for the people I know at Veritas
I love them the people I met the people
I mean obviously you you're like my
brother I mean I don't know each other
Band of Brothers yes but you did Henry
the simple few four parts too yeah yes
um and I want you guys to succeed
O'Keefe why do you think that do you
think that there's a way for these
organizations to both just keep firing
on all cylinders absolutely
I wish them well I hope they keep I hope
they do what they do I want everyone to
do this
I think everyone should do this I don't
think people should stop people from
doing this
I don't think we should I don't I don't
think it's uh I think it's an uh against
the First Amendment to stop journalism
and stop trying to use the federal
courts to stop journalists I've been
sued so many times in my life I had the
teachers union in Michigan file an
injunction against me in 2017 Randy
Weingarten actually filed a restraining
order against me because I published a
document showing they paid off fifty
thousand dollars to someone who's
accused of raping a child wow and they
issued an injunction in federal court
against any now I defeated that
injunction they they were demanded well
they initially got it it was a temporary
restraining order in federal court in
Michigan this is still this is still
going on five years later I haven't
settled the cake now I'm not in charge
there anymore
but you see what's at stake here oh so
your ass like okay Veritas I saw yours
well no but I do I didn't I didn't want
that to be the case no I know yeah but
whoever is in charge has to now deal
with this this dichotomy of okay I gotta
raise ridiculous amounts of money to
fight on principle or I can settle and
give up so in Michigan this was this was
a document where it was paid off 50
Grand we got the guy in hidden camera
saying he knows what he did we published
a story we get sued no one comes to our
defense
hundreds of thousands of dollars I'm
deposed I go through depositions in um
with these with these lawyers for the
teachers unions and and that's its own
form of torture
um but uh but that's the price you pay
so for this company OMG for O'Keefe
Media Group are you is it like you're
obviously private right now do you have
any ambition to take it public
that's that's such a uh I'm taking it
one one week one month at a time
probably not I mean I'm I'm I've I've
trust issues right now yeah with
ownership
um I 100 own it I haven't taken on any
debt
um
no equity I we had a very successful
launch we have thousands of paid
subscribers which is pretty good for an
organic launch yeah
um and we'll take it from there we do
have a 501c3 and C4 that I'm not on the
board of I posted that link to my
Twitter Liberty guard to C4 they're
gonna help pay for legal defense to pay
for lawyers and and private citizen
which is a 51c3 liberty guard and
private citizen if you want to donate
and get a tax deduction to help pay our
legal costs you can donate to to those
organizations are you with them do you
work for them no their boards just are
their mission is to is to defend
citizens who are being under attack and
being silenced uh like in this case so
they'll take donations to support uh
paying the attorneys so it's just insane
how much of this is lawyers and just
legal fees people have no people have no
people have no idea I didn't I mean well
I knew that for what you were doing you
ended up getting sued a number of times
so I figured that that was a problem for
you I didn't realize how much that added
up well it was also like the legal Court
the system's expensive case in 2019 jury
verdict in North Carolina you probably
none of you knew this it was like a jury
verdict woman sues me for defamation for
quoting I quoted we quoted Scott Vogel
and Scott Fogle is saying what he said
and they sued me I don't know why
they're suing me they should sue Scott
foble and it gets all the way I had to
fight it for like two years it goes all
the way right before the verdict the
jury is coming out of the box and the
federal judge gavels the case and goes
and I'm paraphrasing a federal judge
article 3 judge says can someone please
tell me why we're here wow and and the
lawyers the plaintiff's lawyers these
are these are like the Hillary Clinton
sort of make money group right I don't
know how this old woman could afford
like five lawyers that's another story I
had two one of them was blind the and
that was intentional because the jury
sympathized with him as much as I did to
her justice is Blind Justice is blind
and and the judge goes if you is
directed at this is a transcript
directed at the Lord if you sued Mike
Wallace I realized Mike Wallace is dead
60 minutes but if you sued Mike Wallace
for what you're suing James O'Keefe for
everyone would laugh at you
and you should have seen the look on
these lawyers faces
they were like whoa we didn't expect
that so sometimes you have to fight it
all the way to join legal fees it took
last year we won back 15 grand
because in the United States it's capped
yeah right you don't you don't we got
administrative fees back oh so that
covered what wonderful faxes and like
copy scans and things like that I think
people need to understand this
if someone sends you a demand letter or
a threat or an intent to file and you go
to your lawyer and say okay how should
we respond to this they'll say well
we'll draft a response 15 grand bang
that's why everyone loves lawyers so
much yep
I blame the lawyers you've you've got a
firm of people they got three people on
it they the the really good lawyers
charge a lot of money because they're
really good and you want to win but I
mean look I get it but I'm just saying
it's it's it's it's absurd it's
ridiculous how expensive but I want but
there's a point buried there that I want
your audience to understand we I had to
fight it all the way
I think I think that I'm I'm saying the
cost of the total cost of that one deal
1.5 mil
1.5 million to do the right thing
cost me 1.5 million and what did I get I
got a check for 15 grand four years
later in crickets I would not and I'm
not complaining I'm not a victim I don't
want your pity I don't want your
sympathy I am trying to make a point do
you know how many late night dinners
how many car rides how many airplane
trips away from my loved ones that I had
to take to raise that money to pay those
lawyers and by the way more power to the
lawyers it's the free market they
deserve to get paid a thousand dollars
an hour and they won
but the price that has to be paid
is is so
Central to the journalism itself you
can't tell the story without also paying
that price and nobody gets that but but
James wouldn't you have rather
spent a million and a half dollars on
like some beachfront property in Atlanta
I could have something I could have
I could have spent that money on a
hundred other things
but I cared so much
in that Federal article 3 judge
reitzinger was in his name
reading the riot act to those lawyers
and by the way cameras are not allowed
in Federal courtrooms I wish they were
but there's a transcript you can read it
I think there's a there's relatively few
people left
who admire the abstract when it comes to
Value I think you're one of them and
what I mean is
as I mentioned before vanity played a
role in why news organizations would do
serious investigations why they would
expose government malfeasance why they
would publish the Pentagon papers or the
Afghan war logs and things like that and
it was that
it feels good to be recognized for doing
something good and we've lost and we're
losing a lot of that in our society so
my my assumption James is that when it
comes on like this I feel similarly I I
say this would I rather have like I
don't know a Ferrari in an infinity pool
or would I rather have really great
journalists do you know that when that
when that gavel came down it's called a
rule 50 directed verdict directed
verdict means you know a judgment
notwithstanding the verdict or right
before the verdict and the judge
dismissed the case wow everyone that
worked with me in that courtroom was
crying I was crying Russ verney at the
time what was our head of our legal
department was crying
my blind lawyer was hugging me
I cannot describe the feeling it felt
like to be in the right because every
once in a while there is a taste of
justice but how did it get so far yeah
that's a rhetorical question
it our system is is a little broken
and and the system of justice is broken
and that's horrible couldn't this
couldn't this judge right away just been
like summary dismissal get out of my
courtroom right away he's got a duty to
get those lawyers paid let's be honest
motion to dismiss you could have won on
motion to dismiss I mean I I was
prejudiced as you get in my courtroom
don't come back we also sued the New
York Times for defamation and got past
motion to dismiss yeah and I was about
to head toward you know Tucker Carlson
was removed from Fox News and we see all
these text messages right and let me let
me go through all your phones Daily
Beast New York Times reporters and look
at your text messages to people let me
let me see you wanna if you want to live
in let's live in that world and I was
going there
but I'm not in charge anymore
oh so that loss is still ongoing yeah
wow I mean this could be a big part of
it
I mean somebody meets with somebody else
and they say hey look man this O'Keefe
things really bad for everybody why
don't we grease your wheels a little bit
and you make it go away it's crazy
what's it worth the way that 501c3s are
organized is so it's like no fault
divorce like you have you need three
people to start a thing and then the two
of them can immediately get you thrown
out I don't even think they just come
together and like we had a board meeting
you're out you're like dude I just I
just paid six grand to start this thing
and they're like yeah we decided you're
out
where's the charity like where I
understand you can get free money
donated but I don't trust nonprofits I'm
in the I'm in the process of starting
one right now and it's like geez I'm
sweating it's it's it's it's so insane
you have to find really strong people
and the question is how do you evaluate
whether someone is strong I mean you
don't really know until you go through
hell with them so you so you have to go
through that to establish whether they
have testicular fortitude you know that
that Henry V
um quote that we were in recite their
manhood
for he today who sheds his blood with me
shall be my brother this story shall the
good man teach his son
for he today who goes through hell with
me shall be my brother be him never so
vile however Low born a man may be this
day shall make him a man and gentlemen
in England now Abed shall stand a curse
they were not here
and hold their manhoods cheap while any
speaks that fought with us on this day
the people that remain by my side
you know like RC you know I'm getting
emotional here but they're like
they're like my brothers
they have been through hell
they have been through absolute hell
and I have seen
such goodness in people
um while also seeing evil but the things
that keep me going is the goodness
you know in people and there's a lot of
good people out there you know what's
some of the best stuff you've seen
the people out there in the country who
who message me and say I will always
have your back and I want to do what you
do
and I need your help to do it those are
people keep me going
are you inspiring people to start their
own companies
I mean we I want to inspire people to go
do what I do because I think they can
take
take down one man but they can't take
down
thousands of people I think they can
they can defeat one man but they can't
defeat an army they can't defeat an army
of people
or multi-million dollar lawsuits massive
multinational corporations I'm
ultimately not worried about the money
because I think it can be raised it's
not a zero-sum game
um
if I have to raise 50 million I'll raise
it
whatever it takes will do it to get the
job done because there's so many people
in this country like I go the airports
and TSA and backseat of uber I mean the
people that like even I'm sure you get
recognized all the time Tim but like
it's it's crazy
I mean I had dinner the other night in a
restaurant someone ten times in a row
they came up to me
and they all say please never give up
please stop doing don't ever stop doing
what you're doing please don't ever give
up they're begging me
not to give up so that that and that
that keeps me going and and uh I went to
a small farm store
about six seven months ago
and uh was in there just shopping little
local produce stuff they asked me what I
did and I was like I you know I do a
political show and stuff they're like oh
really cool really cool what's it called
and I said it's all called Tim cast and
they're like oh that's really really
great and you know what do you talk
about I was like oh this that or
otherwise and they're like you know I
love and I was like oh and like James
O'Keefe he's so great do you know James
okay if I'm like I've heard of him yeah
he's really great and they were like we
need more people like him and I'm just
sitting here like this is really cool
man I know that guy the balance is like
because people are gonna name their kids
after you probably YouTube but like your
ego come on man how do you balance your
ego like I imagine the last couple years
was insane for you like just so
much pressure and focus on you and your
name and like the that's a good question
and and and and in many ways you have to
be wired a certain way I think if you're
an artist
you're not a political person I think
the the the game the the process they
put you through
prevents your ego from being a thing in
the first place because of the
responsive power is nothing more than
responsibility so when you're when you
have to raise a hundred grand a day like
that'll that'll mess up your ego because
uh gotta wake up at 6am I gotta work
till one in the morning I gotta run the
company be the face be the talent and
deal with all these lawsuits when you're
a witness in federal court that'll get
your ego destroyed real fast
um
you you you you you people don't realize
that power is nothing more than just
responsibility and when you have all
this response I mean
the FBI came my apartment Point guns at
me take my stuff
it's like a sort of Damocles hangs over
your head and at any moment in time and
then you think oh they're going to get
me on the instruction of justice and
perjury that that that that that process
will humble you real fast your office is
destroyed by a hurricane mine was I had
to rebuild it I'd raise you know so
you you your ego you'll get you'll get
destroyed your ego will get destroyed I
think I'm I'm a fortunate man because
this process I've been through over the
last six months it like
it it it humbled me but it didn't
destroy me
and I think and I think that's rare for
a man to to go through that yeah there's
a a really great quote what you're
saying reminds me of the uh venerable
Archbishop fault machine once said that
maturity is pain plus responsibility uh
and I I think that Rings true here a lot
of people have pain inflicted upon them
but then they don't carry in a
responsible way and so they never
develop as they they need to they want
all of the Power with none of the
accompanying responsibility and it's
nothing but responsibility when you're
in charge of an outfit like that and um
it is a spiritual war now and humility
is an ingredient for
a work ethic I think you said a moment
ago that um something the effect of
money is responsibility or power is
responsibility I think there's an
interesting moral dichotomy the left
views uh doesn't agree with the idea of
power being responsibility they believe
power is something to be is for them to
wield for their own luxuries and desires
and then there are people on this side
who view it as a responsibility to those
who have who have uh
given you a portion of their power so
that you can can concentrate that
I think about that with uh you know what
we do here and what our goals are I see
that in what you do and with what your
goals are that every day and I'll get as
nerdy as possible for all the anime fans
it is Goku doing the Spirit Bomb for
those that aren't familiar it's in
Dragon Ball Z when Goku asks all of the
life of the world to lend him power so
that he can defeat the bad guy that's
how I view power those are the things I
grew up seeing and and you know I know
it's dorky nerdy whatever people who
aren't fans of anime but the idea is as
a child I'm growing up looking up to the
heroes who say please
but a small piece of your power so that
I can do something great the
responsibility to wield that power
responsibly that the requirement that
you do it
is is a moral obligation in my opinion
so for everybody who gives timcast.com
and becomes members sure I could say
we're a for-profit company I deserve
this money I built it I'm gonna do
whatever I want with it I don't we
launched The timcast Newsroom which is a
which is a financial detriment in a
sense we we lose money having
journalists do this work as you should
but we have to do it because there's two
ways I see it one we do an opinion news
commentary show it is not the hard
groundbreaking uh journals in that
project Veritas was doing under you or
what you're doing now with OMG but I
think it's you're probably one of the
best in the business when it comes to
that beat I appreciate it but I also
recognize what we have to as people are
basically saying like we love this show
and what you talk about we're going to
give you a small piece of the power that
we've accrued so that you can wield it I
don't immediately say something like ah
man it'd be really cool if I built like
a massive Skyscraper with an infinity
pool I think let let's hire a whole
bunch of journalists and take that
energy and focus it into something
massively net positive for the world
that's why even when it comes to like
the coffee company we started I'm in the
whole 250 000 on starting the coffee
company because we need to build
products that compete in the cultural
space I'm in the whole another couple
hundred thousand on starting the coffee
shop because we need to compete with
wealth corporations it you know I think
about it all the time I'm like man
if I shut all this down and just did one
small YouTube channel where I made three
videos per day I would live like a king
and never have to sweat ever again but I
but
there someone has to be
calling out what they see as Injustice
someone has to be like you James
actually doing the work and inspiring
others to go and and and build strong
moral Frameworks for our country and
inspire people to be good people and to
do the right thing and that is we have
an obligation to the people of our
country and our planet
to use our abilities for the betterment
of the world and for the people with
great I'll I'll say like this with great
power comes great responsibility but
Power isn't just one day you stumbled
across a winning lottery ticket power
isn't just you made a lot of money at
your job power is you're talented you're
smart you're capable I believe that we
as humans have an obligation to to the
best of our abilities use our gifts so
that we can make the world better for
everybody else absolutely we'll I mean
that that's a of an important Christian
belief we will be held accountable for
our talents at the end of our life and
it's how we use them it's their gift not
to shy away from some kinds of pain you
guys are mentioning pain earlier I think
how did you phrase that that there's oh
yeah I quoted the venerable Archbishop
fault machine or venerable Archbishop
bullshin he said that maturity is pain
plus responsibility I've been thinking
about pain because there's different
kinds of pain there's some types of pain
that are like stop doing this whatever
is happening right now make it stop
because this is an indication of paying
that there's damage being done then
there's other kind of pain that
indicates growth like the breakdown out
of muscle so that it can regrow it's
very true yeah if you can withstand that
kind of pain and understand the
difference between that and actual
warning signs and another thing that
Roseanne Barr told me recently was that
and I hope I'm not breaking your
confidence but I intend to visit with
her in Texas soon as we're like she's a
creative I'm a creative I don't know
about I I assume you're creatively
motivated we're quiet we make music and
art right right you give your music
business and everything I mean I'm a
creative so that's what motivates me I'm
motivated by like creating the project
telling the story doing the thing
um creative people this this whole
process has created a little
disillusionment in me which at first I
thought well that's not good because am
I going to lose my idealism
but Roseanne Barr told me that what
makes a great artists if you're an
artist illusion separates you from God
and separates you from reality if you're
dissolute if you're if you're getting
rid of your Illusions you're going to do
a better job of capturing reality
and we are witness to reality if you're
a reporter you're reporting on the truth
you're reporting on the world around you
if you're an artist you're doing the
good the true and the Beautiful so to be
disillusioned I think is a good thing
it's a sign of wisdom and to your point
about muscle that's a great metaphor
like I totally agree with that you you
go through I mean the pain is like
Beyond The Sword of Damocles the FBI
that's still ongoing I'm still under
Federal criminal investigation like
three years later they have all my stuff
it's a sort of Damocles it's painful but
you become stronger for it and it's
going to prepare you for the next thing
which is worse but hey
your muscles are bigger by the way some
guys know where the gym is dude there's
no Keith by the way get ripping up 20
pounds of muscle do I look like I know
where the gym is James come on do you
are you religious man I am I am a
religious man yes I'm a Believer were
you always
I don't know I don't know how to answer
that I think I think uh no no I think I
think it's it's changed throughout my
life do you find that like that you've
become more spiritual definitely
definitely especially in the last year
and a half I think it by
what what I don't know what pill there
is white black red green I don't know
how many pills all sorts of colors I
don't even know what that means the
thing the moment it hit me the moment I
was like whoa because I've been doing
this since I was College it was was um
when I was banned from Twitter in in
April of 2021 that's when it hit me I
was like this I said shit's about to get
real that that was the moment for me for
whatever reason that was just I woke up
I was like oh my God it took away my
main distribution mechanism wow and then
Elon led us back on December 2022 a
month before the Pfizer story which was
God's timing that was your biggest story
providential Praise Jesus that was that
was 40 50 million views wow which is
like more views than like the the World
Cup scoring video like that was that was
that was by a factor of 20. white pill
crazy white pill white that moment is
the white pill the moment optimism you
you you begin to feel that you're on the
path of success and that goodness and I
confronted that Pfizer guy in the
restaurant in New York I don't know if
you guys remember this oh yeah yeah they
locked me in the restaurant if you
haven't seen this it's like a sitcom
it's wild and the guy's like a high up
at Pfizer and he's and they lock me in
which is like I guess false imprisonment
in Brooklyn this is in Dumbo Brooklyn
and I'm being locked in the restaurant
and and the guy is smashing he he takes
the iPad out of my hand I know you do a
good Chris Hanson impression as long as
you drink a Zen over there that's
unbelievable thank you thank you what
were you thinking messaging a minor
so I walk up to the Pfizer executive
like Chris Hansel I'm like is this seat
taken I remember it was it was a
brilliant what's my life forgot my line
you were like can I see it here can I
sit um is this seat taken and the guy's
like he goes to the five stages of grief
in two minutes it's really remarkable oh
my God which is the name of my company
that's that's a double pun and he goes
oh my God and he goes you can't be here
you can't do this and then he goes I'm
literally a liar
I'm literally a liar it's like but you
expect me to believe everything you're
telling me right now
and then he proceeds to smash the device
as if the only location of the video is
on that particular device that I had
he's smashed this is this is the guy who
went to Yale Medical School smashing and
meanwhile he's he he like assaults my
crew and I'm backing up
and I'm backing up and I'm thinking here
you know what I'm thinking I'm thinking
I need to make sure that this whole deal
is recorded because the cops are coming
oh man and and then and then a week
later I was removed from from uh project
veritas
it's hard not to think that it was
connected
was just getting so big that it hit some
sort of breaking point right I had a
I hear a lot of stories where people say
something like oh my friend recommended
this this uh mind-altering drug and I
don't mean illegal ones I mean legal
ones they're like have you thought about
anti-anxiety medicine or depression
medicine
people are on how many pills these days
yeah I think even Family Guy made a joke
about it where uh Lois like cracks a
bunch of different pills and she's like
all of my different prescriptions and
then eats them and she's like tomorrow I
think this is a new idea or something
like that like
something is is going on in this country
with big pharmaceutical companies in
terms of just Mass cranking out so many
different drugs and they have they make
such tremendous profits and they sponsor
so many different media organizations
that all of a sudden big companies are
like hey nobody bad mouth our sponsors I
don't know if you saw the story did OMG
two weeks ago with the Tucker or the Fox
News nightly producer saying that the
advertising dollars influence and fight
we get money from Pfizer and
um I did a podcast with Robert Kennedy I
intend to interview Trump Kennedy and
DeSantis but I did an hour-long deal
with with Kennedy and he told me a story
of when when he was uh talking to
someone at Fox I think it was ales at
the time who were laid to him that if
you go on the air and talk about this
stuff Rupert Murdoch will will kick you
off the air so this is real this is you
know this is a real influence
um and I think the story is just to your
point I think it's going more of it's
going to come out I don't think we've
we're not done with the Pfizer beat
don't you worry I think what uh what we
see with you James with OMG with what
you were previously doing with Veritas
just your work in general and the people
you've inspired
we need people young people growing up
knowing that you will be championed you
will be not only championed by your
peers
you will you will actually do good
things that help make the world better
if you stand up for on strong moral
grounds yes reject corruption and so
when I hear that story of the of the the
guy in in the uh this the store and you
know he works for um Pfizer and all that
he said I'm a liar and then he tries to
smash the device and I'm thinking about
here's a guy who will privately to a
random person admit to malfeasance but
then once he finds out people might
realize he's doing wrong he tries to
destroy the evidence and lie about it
because he knows he is doing evil and he
is scared that people will find out
that's just that's kind of a scary thing
he literally says it's bad for America
in the video yeah right it was insane it
was like a cartoon I literally made a
cartoon of it but it was hard to parody
because about over the top it was I
couldn't believe this guy was openly and
at one point he's like you're not like
one of those hidden camera guys are you
I was oh my goodness yeah they can't
they can't that that's why people don't
do this because it would it would expose
themselves it would expose the whole
rotten thing what you're going to say
something no I I just we need to get to
the point where we restore this sense of
I can't do that that's wrong yeah
instead of I'll do that as long as no
one finds out well because that's
ridiculous exactly we don't care if we
do the right or wrong thing we care
about our reputation that's it that's
right that that that's exactly it and
there's there's a weakness it's it what
people are forgetting is like it's not
necessarily these are bad people they're
they're weak people I've seen a lot of
weak people and when you're doing the
right thing sometimes you can't be like
a nice guy you can't just go along with
it you have to take a stand and and and
that and that that moral compass is is
is everything the weakness versus the
strength is what I would say is the
problem we need strong people I know
it's a cliche but and then you have to
figure out how how do you how do you
test for that I think about uh that
mentality of you know this guy does
something he knows is wrong and bad and
harmful as long as nobody finds out
and it's it's remarkable to me because
I'm wondering does he have no Scruples
does he have no inner sense of I just
can't bring myself to do this that it's
I just don't understand how people could
have this within them to say yeah I got
no problem doing it as long as nobody
finds out there was one time that the
Twitter guy was on a date with the
undercover journalist and he goes don't
tell anybody this but here's a secret
email that that the the project eratos
sent out and our reporter has to has to
mispronounce project project varieties
in order to not be burned so they
everything
no offense to like your reporter I was
like that is the most like I'm clearly
pretending not to be in Project Veritas
statement I've ever heard but the guy
still keeps confessing I'm sitting here
and I'm being texted by my team and they
they're reminding me that every time
they're on an assignment the reporters
are you know the subjects are asking are
you are you you've got the hidden camera
are you working for James O'Keefe they
always say and then they still tell them
all their information everything it's
insane everything because it has to do
with I guess a a narcissistic uh trait
and and humans where they just can't
they can't admit that how did you put it
they can't admit they're wrong they're
how did you say that earlier because you
were on point evil exists in people and
and um they're fine with doing it so
long as no one finds out that's right
that's right that's exactly right I
think what happens there is sort of a
microcosm of a much larger human problem
which is that when people don't develop
virtue what they've essentially failed
to do is subjugate their emotions or
their passions to reason so even though
they know okay it wouldn't be reasonable
for me to tell someone I barely know
every borderline illegal or flat out
illegal or unethical thing I'm doing at
work I feel like I want to in the moment
so I'm going to right and one of the
other questions we if I'm an undercover
reporter and someone's saying hey are
you I say hey yes you want to check me
you want to check my body and they'll
never do it and and the thing about it
psychologically is that undercover work
is about is about asking them about
themselves people have talked about
themselves so it's remarkable what
people will confess if you express
interest in them personally well you're
familiar with this meme remember this
one yeah this is the hot crazy access
for for women you date
and it's like you know if a woman is a
five or below you don't you know it's
like a no-go Zone if she's you know the
crazy access is a 10 it's a no-go Zone
then you have the crazy Zone The Fun
Zone the date Zone and then women who
are not crazy and super attractive it's
James O'Keefe spying on that or or it's
a dude isn't it or like the lower right
when it's oh they replaced that with
James okay so like this was after the
Twitter thing when we were like so I
can't remember you were cracking up no
we were watching it laughing and then I
we you and I were coming up someone
tweeted it they were like if you are a
like mildly unattractive Tech engineer
for a big tech company and this hot
woman is asking you about the inner
workings of your company it's James
O'Keefe well I just love the idea I mean
are these people watching pickup artist
videos where the pickup artist is like
you want to get a girl tell her every
illegal thing you've ever done on the
first date drives them crazy you see the
story we did last week on fetterman
where the guy this is fetterman's aide
he carries around his stuff and any and
he's and he's you probably do a great
impression but he's like we just I'm not
incoherent enough we just use the
journalists as puppets like they do
everything we tell them to they're not
they're not skeptical like he's bragging
yeah about this and the dude in the
Pfizer he's brag he's bragging about
you know mutating viruses and hurting
people why would you know they're
bragging about these things to try to to
what to get laid I think I know what it
is well I think that's part of it I
think when someone is doing something
horrible they feel a need for that
behavior to be accepted by other people
right their conscience is bothering them
and they want to sit across from
somebody who will say yeah of course
there's nothing wrong with that or I
agree that's really funny and
interesting so that when those thoughts
come into their mind that maybe I'm
doing the wrong thing they can try to
fall back on well the other people I've
spoken to approve of it they're dying to
confess this is what you're desperate to
confess the people who are in your face
about their lifestyle choices the most
are always the people who feel guilty
about what they're doing and they need
your approval because they don't have
the approval of their conscience
it's profound that's very true I don't
think anyone's ever spoken about this in
this way by the way some of them don't
we don't find them on dating apps in
fact the one guy
reporter that works for me got a guy in
December in Chicago uh to talk about the
remember the dildo butt plug story
I I don't remember
private school the head of a private
school in Chicago talks about giving out
these things to children oh my God he
met he met that man in a in an airport
security line so wow that's how he got
that information did he have to like I'm
gonna go to the bathroom and then put
the camera on and like oh geez he he bit
winning friends and influencing people
and the confession thing you said is
very profound it's it's really true dude
confession is innately necessary for
humans man that religion had it the
correct the church and that I was right
with internet video you can like tell
the world your secrets it's humiliating
but you can and it it they stop popping
into your head like you stop your
conscience becomes clear when you tell
someone this this thing and it's very
that's why I say we hold a mirror up to
people I I think Sheamus nailed it I
think a lot of these people it it it's a
joke that we've pointed out where you
know a guy meets a woman he sits down
and says hey babe you want to hear about
all the illegal things my company does
like it's gonna score them but but
that's not it Sheamus I think Nails it
in that the moment they engaged in
something they knew was wrong their mind
said you are doing wrong stop and they
didn't they weren't strong enough to say
no so when they sit down with someone in
private they're looking for validation
exactly they're begging please tell me
I'm a good person and I think there's an
additional element that wants validation
in a different way I think their
conscience wants validation as well they
want to hear that person say you're
better than this stop yeah this is this
is profound dialogue here about what we
do and and how it works the confession I
think that's right and there's this one
example I have in my mind of Charlie
Chester who is a CNN guy about two years
ago and the whole time he's Bret waxing
euphoric about how much propaganda CNS
he never looks into the eyes of the
person across the table from him it's
almost like he's talking to himself or
to you know a monologue not with the
person he doesn't even care about them
he's just hearing listening to himself
talk so their conscience goes against
their own actions for sure yep you can
tell a lot by looking in somebody's eyes
the brain because it says to the brain
it's a the eyes are connected directly
to the brain like it can't lie you can
sense it I think it's more than just the
brain right because humans we're not
just bodies we're Body Soul composite
and there there is a there there now you
you can tell you're not just looking at
matter when you look into somebody's
eyes there's something else We're Not
Mere mechanical components there's
something more to us yeah and the way
it's moving you can tell it's vibrating
you know different ways depending on
what they're thinking but even vibration
puts it in a material way like there's
something immaterial that we we can't
understand the the conscience thing is
really interesting to me because when in
your life did someone come to you and
say son I know you're entering
kindergarten it's your first day but if
you ever work for a major pharmaceutical
company and they ask you to engage and
gain a function research I need you to
say no son it's wrong that never happens
in your life so something throughout
this person's life generated the moral
understanding that this practice would
be wrong what do you think that is
well I wonder I wonder if there is
something genuinely immaterial in that
we know when we're doing good or bad it
more relates to
do we know that this is going to be
harmful to the world and our fellow man
and it I I think maybe that's just a
there could be something more
metaphysical or maybe it's simply that
we know the destruction of the planet we
know that harming others is just
inherently wrong and working to those
ends is wrong yeah but they want to
justify it somehow and and be told
everything's okay you're you're a good
person well I think we have a culture
that celebrates Vice and denigrades
virtue and as I mentioned earlier when
we're referring to Virtue what we're
really referring to is subjugating your
impulses your passions your emotions to
reason doing the right thing in spite of
the way you feel what we have encouraged
people to do systematically over the
last several decades is to orient
themselves towards pleasure is the
highest good and that includes ignoring
your conscience ignoring reason ignoring
your values just doing what feels good
and what results from that is a person
who is incapable people of going against
their own passions in doing what's right
and so other people not liking you it
makes you feel bad they don't want that
negative consequence of their nefarious
behaviors but but the conscience part of
it doesn't factor in as often until they
need to silence it by getting your
approval no no bro it's much easier than
that they sell these wonderful little
pills that turn that conscience right
off so you've got people who know it's
wrong that's true that's true yeah this
is this is the vision that I'm seeing as
you're explaining this I'm imagining
some morbidly obese woman eating her
fifth bowl of nachos
with her brain screaming stop doing this
and she goes oh the negative thoughts
are coming back
that's right negative thoughts are gone
sometimes you are supposed to feel
negative thoughts negative thoughts are
not a disease sometimes they're a
symptom of you doing something wrong you
have to stop doing that thing instead of
medicating yourself there are people who
can't feel pain yeah
and I've heard a lot of people say wow
that would be so awesome to not have to
feel pain and what they don't realize is
it's actually terrifying and dangerous
they almost pull their eyes out as
infants and they'll think they can't
sweat yeah because the the pain is what
I read was that certain people who can't
experience pain their body can't
regulate temperature because they don't
have that sensation of discomfort and so
they could easily overheat and die they
also sometimes could bite through their
tongue when they're little kids they can
seriously injure themselves and not know
crazy stories
hardship is a good thing yeah nagging
negative feelings not always bad things
I understand sometimes there's chemical
imbalance depression and anxiety where
people are having a disorder right but
perhaps if you are unhappy
not everybody I know sometimes people
are you know clinically or medically
depressed but perhaps
you need to do better by yourself you
need to eat right you need to exercise
you take responsibility for yourself
born with the spark of the Divine and it
is through the drugs and the the what
they're exposed to we suppress it we
suppress it but they're born with that
desire because I feel like
the word truth speaking the truth makes
people feel free
the subjects that I right the true shall
set you free Veritas
speaking the truth makes you feel free
and and many ways this is what you're
this guy is good I've never said it
never heard it said that way thank you I
mean the subjects are engaging in
confession which makes them feel it's
therapy for them yeah but the difference
is they don't get Absolution yup that is
the difference
no because the difference is when you go
to confession when you go confess to a
Catholic priest with true Contrition
you're actually sorry you're actually
making a resolution not to do it again
he you're not going in there and saying
this is the thing I did please give me
your approval you're saying this is
wrong I know it was wrong please absolve
me I'm sorry right but that's not what
they're doing they want to confess it
but in a way where they don't admit it's
wrong and they get your approval your
approval is their God you James you're
you're effectively an an inverse priest
for them in a certain way where instead
of saying admit you are wrong they're
saying please tell me I wasn't exactly
there's something to that because and
then an exposure but but real quick
sorry I just wanted to add
what these people need to understand and
what always breaks my heart about the
videos that you put out James when it's
like a Twitter engineer who says yeah
we're doing these things why wasn't he a
whistleblower why didn't he say I am
going to reach out to James O'Keefe
personally and of my own volition and
tell him about these horrible things
they're doing I have a good answer for
that it's one one word two syllables
paycheck yeah the god of money that's
what I've been thinking about I wasn't
you know that's not really what
motivates me but but a lot of otherwise
I thought decent people
will just stay there for the paycheck I
think and and we've talked about Tim you
know I talked about this before well
that there are cowards and yeah there's
some something to that
um but I think that's changing in
society I uh to be a little optimistic
here I think people now care more about
um doing the right thing more than they
ever have
but they need a leader they need someone
to follow people people like I have to
give people permission
like people are watching from the
sidelines with a tit with a pinky toe in
the pool well I think I they're drafting
an email right now to O'Keefe tips at
protonmail.com
should I do this I got the mortgage I
got the wife I got the this like it's
always the wife or something like this
it's I've got the kids and I I always
say like you get the kids okay well but
your kids don't they want to look up to
their parents and don't they I mean I
had someone tell me oh you're really
lucky you don't have children and one
day I'll be a father hopefully soon but
like really I'm lucky I don't have
children yeah I would think that my
children would would hopefully look up
to someone who stands on principle even
if it cost me my paycheck
you know and and these are these are
there's nothing new Under the Sun we've
talked about these concepts for millions
of thousands of years but I think things
are changing I really do people are you
mention people on the sidelines and they
need permission
I've had so many people ask me
especially you know when I was working
for vice when I was on the ground field
reporting I would get these emails and
people would say how do I do what you do
and I'd say oh it's really really easy
take out your phone press record
there you go there's have a nice day and
they're shock like what that can't be
right I'm like dude I was living in New
York filming things that were going on
there like I moved I went there for 20
bucks on a bus to Occupy Wall Street I
just started filming stuff
so like when you told that story of the
woman who you know you said have you
gone to your public schoolmings I didn't
know I could there's a lot of people who
don't realize there is nothing stopping
you from entering The Fray of the
political the fear right fear a fear of
unknown sure but I mean like
you know I thought about this when I was
younger how do you
get involved and say like the
conversation we are having someone might
be wondering like how do I get on a show
like that well you just start doing
these things you show up to events you
speak you be present in the moment you
film you record there are a lot of
people who got started by just showing
up and being like hey I'm here here's
what I think and then more and more
people start noticing they're there and
they think things and they're speaking
out more and more people started going
to school board meetings and speaking up
and getting attention you just have to
do it and be the person leading the
charge also ditch Hedonism this
obsession with uh feeling good and
avoiding pain is is it's a detriment you
gotta Embrace pain and it sounds
sadistic to say that because like not
all kinds don't seek it out it's not
sadistic it's gonna be there it's there
right now gravity is painful we're being
sucked down and twisted to this earth it
hurts well the deal with the first
chapter of the book I wrote American
muckraker is called suffering that the
first chapter is about pain and and um
and I and I
read Because of Jordan Peterson Gulag
archipelago that's great the sultanitsin
guy talks about in the gulags and
there's this one part of this story that
just I'll rarely resonated with me he's
in the gulags we always joke that I'm
gonna go to the gulags right so joke
joke yeah maybe it's happening
yeah but is it that is that the worst
outcome like RFK told me which is very
profound I was like I said aren't you
worried these pharmaceutical companies
are going to kill you and he goes
there are things in life worse than
dying
so Sultan Eason says he's in the gulags
and he's and he's there's a hunger
strike
and he writes about this and and because
when you're on a hunger strike you you
you retain some of your own power over
the guards and that gives you a sense of
empowerment because now you have the
power over the forces of evil that are
that are that are imprisoning you
and and one of the guys and the hunger
strike decide you know what I'm too
hungry I'm gonna go eat that piece of
bread
and I'm paraphrasing but sultz Nissan
describes that the pain of these people
are all starving this he's starving to
death the pain of the Betrayal of the
comrade who ate the bread was so much
greater than the pain of the starvation
it's your point about suffering it's
like
what I've been through
I don't view it as a bad thing because I
think that pain completes the process of
muscle development and I have zero
regrets it is it has made me it is going
to make me a more effective messenger
it's going to make me understand who's
real and who's good and who's phony and
who's fake and that's a good thing
that's a good thing we want to know
who's going to eat that bread and I
always say to my friend say to my
colleagues don't eat the bread and the
gulags all right don't eat that bread
well if when we find ourselves in that
Gulag James I will share my bread with
you share your bread with you okay for
the right we'll we'll make sure you know
you're doing good the gulag was the
department that oversaw the prisons the
prisons weren't actually called gulags
fair enough fair point we're gonna go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com because the
members only show will be coming up at
about 10 or so p.m a few minutes
afterwards goes live on the front page
of timcast.com and for those that are
members at the 25 or more level or
you've been a member at any level for at
least six months you can submit
questions call into the show and
actually talk to us and our guests all
right what do we got here grafty says
James is a badass but human I believe he
is indeed he is indeed
all right Brandon Smith says took a bag
of Appalachian nights to work today
figured a Navy base in San Diego is the
perfect place for it by the way it's
delicious I really do appreciate it and
uh I gotta say you know we we put this
blend together it's a bit darker than
your typical dark roast not as dark as
an espresso roast because I like I I
like all coffee to be completely honest
the rise of the Birdo Jr is a light
roast and it's super I love it but man
that Appalachian nights it gets me I end
up chugging my breakfast coffee normally
I always said sip sipping I'd be sipping
it now I'm just slamming it
all right let's grab some more uh
let's grab some more Super chats
Laurel says run a coffee option for
James with the percent of the profits
going to OMG you can call it James o
kafif
uh sure yeah we'll make a we'll make a a
specific blend and then we'll have all
the proceeds go to OMG
my thing is so long as we can here's
what I always tell everybody like look
if this company this coffee company sets
up a bunch of different coffee shops I
think we'll end up franchising because
we just want to get the ball rolling I
don't care to be the CEO of a
multi-billion dollar coffee company
that's meaningless to me what I do care
about is pulling into a shop into a
strip mall to you know with my friends
and we're in the middle of like Omaha
and then all of a sudden like look does
it did you set up a cast crew here no I
thought you did and we're like oh we go
inside and then there's the new OMG
report playing on the TVs at James
O'Keefe and so you get some Suburban mom
and she goes and she's like I just want
a cold brew with some some half and half
and then while she's waiting there's
James O'Keefe from the TV being like
breaking news we got a new report about
act blue ball and she goes oh I didn't
know that creating spaces where regular
people will be exposed to the positive
influence of all the people that in this
field the work you're doing that's our
mission with the with the coffee shop
and the coffee company so absolutely we
can we can launch
make an OMG coffee we'll start on the
website and we'll give you all the
profits wow breaking news he only
offered me half of the profits for the
one he and I are going to do together
this is a very special offer very
special for James O'Keefe well the thing
about and this is true actually the the
the the split rev with Sheamus is that
we're literally just selling a coffee
for profit also no one wants to buy mine
what's it called the thing I'm kidding
we're working on it we had a couple
ideas but we're we we're still probably
tweaking it before we announce I I I I
suppose it might sound a little crude
but you know the reason I say this for
James is that we want to fund the work
no I was just kidding I was just giving
a hard time no I know it's because you
want to fund a stop that's good yeah we
want to fund your stuff too no I know I
appreciate you know cartoons are
substantial they're not important
exactly are you gonna put a cartoon
image I'm only half a thing actually on
your bag oh um yeah no we were talking
about that yeah
and a limited edition run where sipping
some if you want to own the specific art
of the Sheamus Blend or whatever yeah it
takes six six weeks to print the bags
and then you know like seven to ten days
to do the roasting but we're we'll
figure it out coffee boy Cog when they
call it and I'm just saying this on here
if James wants a coffee or whatever I
don't know I would love love that's a
great idea I'd love it no I was honestly
just giving you a hard time are you a
big coffee guy James yeah like probably
like pre-workouts than coffee coffee
kind of makes me crash but I'll make an
exception oh solid all right Stephen
says says James from the lawsuit it
looks like project Veritas is suing to
make you not be a person is that their
goal I quit supporting them since you
left
um I would say
um I would say that
how do I address this um Let me let me
choose my words carefully here
um
that if they CA if they can't if they
give me one moment to collect my
thoughts
um
if they can't
exist without me then then some some
have said that they have to stop me from
doing what I'm doing
um it was said by someone somewhere it
was a someone that said that uh there's
a statement to the effect of we have to
destroy James O'Keefe in order to save
ourselves
now you explained that one to me it just
doesn't it's the inverse if if they if
they came out and said were sorry things
went this way we appreciate all the work
James has done we wish him the best we
hope that he succeeds and we would like
to succeed as well they'd be way better
off yeah yeah I mean like I said that
there's I support everyone doing this I
I wish or more there should be more
organizations doing this I don't think
you should stop a journalist from
exposing corruption with money that was
donated in order to expose corruption
that doesn't make any sense to me it
almost feels like the intention was to
destroy Veritas and and some would say
that they're you know trying to be
trying to
trying to be me but nobody nobody can be
me uh you know and and um uh but I I do
wish people the best I I want people to
expose what needs to be exposed and I
think and I think we can coexist I think
we should I mean more organizations
doing this I think more non-profits ngos
whatever you want to call it nonprofits
are tough though with boards because
again you have that same problem we
talked about throughout the program
which the board has to be very strong
well and also I mean just that statement
we need to destroy him to save ourselves
you know to go out of your way to
destroy someone for your own benefit
that's demonic
like that's a complete inversion we have
an important one from crackling says to
James what happened to retracto the
alpaca will OMG have a new mascot
yes uh the retracto was the mascot that
Andrew Breitbart came up with we were
thinking back in 2010 when I was
arrested there needs to be an uh you
know
an anthropomorphic creature to represent
all the defamation and he's like what
about an alpaca and we just laughed till
we cried we have correcto
oh you you do have that I gave that to
you yeah no that one we bought that one
we bought it was a knockoff so we call
it correcto correcto because uh correcto
is not for when other people correct
about you it's from when we issue
Corrections for our mistakes it's the
inversion of it and we did it as kind of
do you have a theme song No but yeah
the correctional back uh retract though
he's coming I mean it's really good what
mascot should we do I guess is my
question what do you want the OMG mascot
well a llama is retracto in the divorce
was he is retractable gonna spend
visitation with him that's not up to me
oh I'm I'm not in I'm not maybe on the
weekends
the uh scarf that it's wearing is actual
alpaca hair scarf I did not know dude
you should do like a camouflage
a gecko or something that can camouflage
into the wall chameleon yeah I'll take
that under advisement I have to think
about a mascot there's a lot of lies
defamation slander and I did this series
every week every other week about
have you considered a chicken perhaps
why a chicken they're known for their
intelligence and bravery roosters
roosters will sacrifice themselves to
save their hens really yeah and so you
know I I take I and everybody watches
the show knows this because I said 8 000
times but a rooster will run full speed
to its own death to fight a predator if
it buys time for the hens to escape I
think we may have we may have a decision
here the noble rooster and everybody
makes fun of chickens you know and I
think it doesn't need a you need a big
pair here's what I don't like all
animals are scared right how people are
right yes you're a silly rabbit when
people are scared case in point but male
rabbits and female rabbits will both
equally flee but a small rooster if you
walk into that Coop the rooster will
attack you like they're Brave yeah they
got they got coconut it takes it takes
decision
testicular fortitude
to do this
um maybe maybe maybe
um
I'll have to think about this one Tim uh
but I will continue that I've got a lot
of of plans I I can't say what they all
are but
um
I I love doing the retracto because it
was like little wins it was like getting
them right little little victories
everyone loves accountability against
journalists yeah how dare you expose The
Washington Post a Federal Institution
this is like your you do it how dare you
sir
an article about why Star Wars is right
perhaps it used to be that way where
they were the uppity elitists who
thought they were doing good but now
they're more demonic than that like how
dare you James expose us but secretly
some of them are like rooting for me
they're like dming they slide into my
DMs I really like what you're doing
there I just don't want to tell you
here's all the illegal things I'm doing
by the way
I feel like here's an important one I
gotta read it Eric Miller says James
you're the hero of Truth and what you're
dealing with is the hero suffering to be
a hero comes with a price sometimes it's
what or who you love the most but you
keep us honest and so the seed of
Courage uh a seat of Courage us and
encourage us all to fight I think there
might be I think this is like like you
said the subjects treat their you know
undercover meanings like therapy in many
ways this Temple shows like therapy for
me and I would say that some days are
really really hard I think we all know
that it's like life right somebody suck
I mean this is an extreme highs and
extreme low business and and there are
some days where I I literally can't I
can't even begin to describe the how
insurmountable it all feels what do you
do for fun when you're sailing sail I'm
a big I'm a big sailboat guy I got a
sailboat I've sailed up and down the
Northeast and oh wow I love that because
sailing is like it captivates all of
your senses it's physics it's physical
it's math it's balance it's it's
symphonic you got you're one with nature
there's no engine you can like sail sort
of Against The Wind by like moving the
sale you can sew in sailing you can sail
the closest you get to the true wind
it's like a pizza pie you can sail 45
degrees off the wind that's called close
healed close hauled and you're like go
left and right or whatever like when you
when you go off the wind you release the
sail which is a greater degree of angle
against the wind so it's called close
hauled Up Against The Wind and The Boat
heals and you're only going like eight
miles an hour but eight miles an hour to
me sailing feels like jumping out of an
airplane
super cool
very nice all right what do we got here
Thomas tjg says can Target and Bud be
sued by their stockholders for neglect
of fiduciary duties I well the answer is
literally 100 yes you can sue a ham
sandwich in this country will you
succeed I think the answer is
probably yes I'm not saying 99 it might
be like 51. but I lean towards in my
complete lack of legal experience which
like I have none but I do believe we've
heard stories of of shareholders suing
because I mean look Bud Light we had the
story we didn't get into any of this
stuff they actually just made another
major contribution to a woke
nonprofit or something
there's literally no business reason to
give hundreds of thousands of dollars to
Pride events especially after your
customers are abandoning you abandoning
you to the tune of 30 of your sales
if you hold stock in Budweiser in
Anheuser-Busch I have to imagine you
have a very strong legal case that they
are intentionally destroying the value
of their company and neglecting their
duties to you the shareholder I mean
that's that's insane like people are
saying like we're boycotting your brand
and then they go I got an idea let's
donate more money to the exact same
thing people are protesting that's the
impact investment and it'll be an
interesting precedent to see if a
company takes 100 million of their
dollars and puts it towards some social
cause that makes no money for their for
their investors but they say but it has
social impact that will benefit you in
the long run stakeholder uh then there
might be some court cases be like no
this is purely fiscal I don't care about
the cleanliness of the air I gave you
money I want money we'll see I think
there's precedent if they keep dumping
money for impact though Paul taskelo
says James I'll provide you with free
legal consultation I can save you tens
of thousands of dollars by just auditing
your legal bills you don't need good
lawyers you need a monster with a law
degree raise his hand
raises yeah I mean please please um oh
it's uh James at O'Keefe medigroup.com
send me an email why not just gave out
my email address who cares yeah but hey
if you get 100 emails and you got to go
through all of them but it's like that's
hey I can do this for you I can do this
for you yeah I mean thank you and and
it's tough that's probably I can't
emphasize to you guys enough that the
managing the lawyers is is hard it's
really hard and the lawyers also don't
want don't want you to say anything and
you know and if you make if you're an
executive you have to make executive
decisions the lawyers resent you for
that because now one side of lawyer say
you're putting my reputation at risk by
by basically being you it's like dude
you work for me like I'm the client and
you're making three times more money
than me which is fine but don't give me
that crap so that's probably that's
something I'm still learning how to do
is manage lawyers manage their legal
bills and um you know and and uh so
thank you whoever you are was his name
uh what was his uh uh Paul taskalos Paul
yeah send me a note and uh we'll talk
we'll touch base thank you make sure you
don't get three or four emails from four
different Paul tasks Don Jr mentioned
this by the way too when he was on our
show about the fact that his lawyers
were advising him not to speak out about
certain things and it ended up working
out very well for him that he did yep
yep
shakenbake says Ian keep moving towards
the light you're almost there almost but
you will never truly get there you can
only get halfway closer in 10 years Ian
is going to be telling Sheamus how he's
wrong about his faith and how you know
like he's he's straying from the light
dude we're on the he's gonna have his
Harris
Ian's gonna be like hardcore like trash
cat like further than me absolutely
there's a magnificent uh religious
Reformation happening right now where
all these Global religions are coming
together with technology and
psychoactive drugs and people are like
trying to figure out the new story we're
gonna tell
I think I think we already told The
Greatest Story Ever Told I think it
really happened time moves backwards and
forwards at the same time that wasn't
exactly what I had in mind
angry marsupial says I left a 14-year
journalism career behind in 2009 because
I saw behind the curtain and became
completely disillusioned corruption in
media government corporations keep
fighting the good fight gents yup
yup yeah I think a lot of it is not even
necessarily good and evil just sometimes
it's just chaos like trying to create
order out of chaos yes you're right
there's a lot of evil though
I worked in nonprofits and small ones I
saw did pretty good but I saw an Untold
amount of corruption lies manipulation
from the biggest to the smallest they
all they cared about was their bottom
line like any company so gross and so I
would I would say most of our profits I
worked at actually told their staff to
lie to people to raise money and I'm
like that's fraud dude like well no if
you say it so I'm like I'm out I'm not
gonna do this it's a quote by Eric
Hoffer every great cause begins as a
movement
becomes a business and eventually
generates into a racket so I found when
I worked in DC when I was 21 I was like
I gotta get out of here like it's crazy
and they can't actually solve the
problem because then they can't raise
money you know you know to try to solve
a problem it's like they can't actually
succeed so so you really have to be like
hyper Vigilant If You're Gonna Keep that
group motivated you have to you have to
again your leadership has to be
in Incorruptible power tends to corrupt
absolute power corrupts absolutely but
Lord Acton said power tends to corrupt
yeah it doesn't always corrupt but it
sure tends to yeah
I'd say federally says so many white
pills hearing how motivated you all are
to keep doing this love you guys love
USA yeah I wonder what it is you know I
I really do
why is it that
James you you are unwavering in your
commitment to a strong moral foundation
and exposing malfeasance and Corruption
well I'm not perfect I have my foul
abilities and I think we all know what
those are
um tough guy to work for don't ask you
how your holidays what holidays were
demanding perfectionist exacting task
master I'm not perfect I'm pretty
disorganized
um
I don't I I I I I I think I think in
many ways I was raised I was raised by
two really good people who I didn't
realize this until my mid-30s I uh
I'm 38 I I have really good mother and
father who were very down to earth
people my grandfather and father worked
really hard uh doing Property
Maintenance I helped them and that kind
of instilled in me kind of a work ethic
but I also feel like again going back to
you as a musician you and I have that in
common I'm a musician I DJ I'm a musical
theater I just love the art artistic
aspects of this and I think our a good
work of art can last a long time
and and I I think the good the true and
the Beautiful that that's what that's
the only way that I can keep doing this
if I focus on the political things or
the you know even the business aspects
of it it just drives me nuts and like
all my people always go back to the
thing that that drives us which is
showing telling the story you know I
don't know if that makes sense but
that's what that's what drives us this
is the way I see it
what are you gonna do with your fifth
house with your third car right you I I
see these big celebrities
I see this this baseball player right
what was his salary like three million
dollars someone mentioned for one year
yeah
yes and so this guy comes out and he's
like I'm so sorry I'll be re-educated or
whatever and I'm like bro
millions of dollars what are you gonna
do with that I just I just genuinely
don't get it
I don't understand this guy's like well
my kids need a vacation home I'm like
bro your kids need a bright future and
an opportunity and a Justin moral
Society
and he has sold that out so that he can
partake in massive amounts of money that
he can't adequately spend like
reasonably they're they're look I I get
it if you've got a couple million bucks
in the bank you're gonna be set for a
long time your family's taken care of
and you can have really nice things and
experience really great things in life
but I'm but I'm looking at it like if
you could buy anything wouldn't you
rather buy a just Society for your
children great Point amen amen what what
else is there worth buying and I've met
a number of philanthropists worth
hundreds of millions or a billion
dollars who who almost grabbed their
colleagues at the country club by the
collar and say are you kidding me you
got 16 Ferraris 500 Grand can can can
buy can buy these this group doing the
right thing or buy a piece of Justice
it's a really really good point and then
and and I and I've been I've done
fundraisers where I speak about these
very issues and what I'm done
I mean this is the audience knows I
drive a Kia and I have a scooter for
real I do have a sailboat that's the one
thing I said I wanted I said I want a
sailboat you deserve a sailboat musk
says I got my private plane okay I got
my sailboat but like I gave these
speeches about like guys like this is
about the the principles and virtue and
truth and Justice and then 30 seconds
after the latest like so tell me about
your curtain rods and they just
transition into this material vanity
and and it's it's frustrating
I'm trying to shake people awake I'm
trying to make people care that's why
that's why the company's called OMG I
got this feeling that if if and when you
die that God is there and it explains to
you what you could have done to make it
right and like all this day we wake up
instead today I'm gonna get the car I'm
gonna go eat I'm gonna get the coffee
I'm gonna play another game of this make
money lifestyle but like in reality we
could get online and make so much noise
and effective change and I think you're
faced with that upon your reconciliation
and it's like God damn it why didn't I
just do it while I was alive and this
this desire to go back and make it right
and then we come back and we forget that
it all that that that that was there and
you have to relearn that and then you
just gotta force yourself man but let a
lonely existence take that idea and
put it into your current life right now
think about where you're at right now
and what you wish you did 10 years ago
to enact something positive now think
about where you are right now and what
your future self will be thinking about
this very moment hindsight is 20 20 of
course so you don't know everything but
you may look you know in 10 years I bet
I'm gonna say I should have done that
one thing and then you probably should
do it let's read this one this was an
important when Quantum strange Quark
says James please make a way to donate
five to ten bucks a month on your
website a lot can't afford a
subscription but still want to donate
yeah if you go to our website right now
we have a we have a C4 and a C3 I'm not
on the board you can donate to help help
us pay our legal bills posted on my
telegram page to James will keep on
Telegram and I've tweeted it out
um uh it's on our website you just go
there scroll down and you can donate to
a to a group that will help pay our
legal bills this one's for you James
Matt from South Dakota says I met my
wife because of James he gave me a VIP
ticket to the project Veritas experience
last year and I met a homeschooled girl
from California we were married six
months later I was the guy that told him
to GTFO on the phone do you remember uh
I think so I but I well my comment on
this is so many people have had babies
because of me it's like mild like I I
decided to become married like like
Hannah Giles like the the uh the my
colleague who who did the acorn story
married Joe Basil who was in a jail cell
with me in Louisiana there are so many
stories like that former colleague in my
Brandon got married uh to a fundraiser
all these families and babies were
created
um now I got it I gotta catch up I gotta
have babies at some point yeah me too
did anyone here have a family no we
don't gotta do it no more you know we're
working on it yeah whatever whatever the
millennial generation is suffering
something you know but I I do think uh
everyone here is actively working on it
so yeah right O'Keefe media I'm also the
youngest so yeah I'm the only one I
blame you guys I'm gonna show you guys
I'm 28. so I'm still look 44. dude back
in the day I would have like 12 kids by
now and have built a log cabin for them
to live in how many kids do you guys
want to have as many as God sends me
good answer yeah wow do you guys have a
number in mind no 50.
100. yeah
all right Cindy drellick says I love
James more than Luke and Ian's hair so
much respect to James fraley's
accomplished despite all the pushback
working in healthcare we have
experienced so many deaths due to
complications of existing conditions
nothing to see here folks
yeah it's sad all right what do we got
here
Kevin Lee says James keep on exposing
and we do all need to address the
corruption wherever we are only wig it
will only way it will get better is if
we get our hands dirty and get in the
game
and sometimes and you know
going back to the sultanites and quote
um in the gulag archipelago the line
that separates good and evil runs
through each and every one of us and
this is like the Peterson Jordan
Peterson talks about like
we all have the capacity to do evil
and when I went through what I went
through particularly in in court and
most recently I could I could actually
feel I could feel the presence of evil
like almost like trying to infiltrate
like my wounds like trying to get inside
of me like I was like I was like warding
it off I was like biting these
forces that were trying to like get
inside of me or something like that and
I know that sounds crazy but I I I
realize this is this is like a spiritual
battle Yeah Yeah and in many ways it's
it's never the enemy like the enemy the
devil you know okay fight the enemy we
have great people many of them are
commenting right now watching this
podcast thank you so much everyone
but it's like the I have to be strong
enough to prevent myself from being
co-opted corrupted influenced softened
um I have to be strong as a human being
and as long as they don't take away my
spirit I can keep going but they but I
can't be Co-op it's a fight that I have
to fight within myself so do you get
sunlight is that like part of it because
I've noticed that I feel like spiritual
resilience when I get enough sunlight
and grounding yeah literally bare feet
in the grass do you do that kind of
stuff touch grass I I do I I I I I do I
mean for me it's being out on the water
taking a walk just looking at nature yes
that's why we're part of it it's great
that's part of it is you got to pray you
gotta you gotta amen you gotta pray
we're gonna go to the members only show
now so smash that like button subscribe
to this Channel and share the show if
you really do think it's important
especially this one if you really liked
it head over to timcast.com click join
us and in a few minutes we will we will
put up the members only live stream show
where we will be taking calls from you
guys our members so smash that like
button you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me at timcast
James do you want to shout anything out
thank you all this has been one of the
most amazing
amazing uh uh interviews slash
discussions I've ever done and um my
main shout out is O'Keefe mediagroup.com
on that website you can donate to our
legal defense fund which I encourage
everyone to do he's taken only afford
two dollars to do that you can sign up
to be a journalist
um and you could subscribe to get our
stuff that's go to our website every one
of you can afford this some one of those
three things one of them is free signing
up to be a journalist doesn't cost you
anything
so
you know there's my pitch O'Keefe
medigroup.com and and thank you Tim for
for doing this thanks for coming yeah uh
Seamus Coughlin Freedom Tunes we make
cartoons uh and if you guys want to
check those out we'll be uploading one
tomorrow and yeah I also want to shout
out what James is doing I think it's
very important work again very important
work and people will follow you on
Twitter James James O'Keefe III James
O'Keefe the third James O'Keefe III at
uh on Twitter you mentioned the RFK uh
Robert F Kennedy podcast do you have a
podcast now that you just started it
yesterday awesome is this on YouTube
it's it's uh behind our paywall but
we're putting out snippets on social
media and and um it's behind our paywall
and it's gonna be different than the
commentary it's going to be it's going
to be in-depth sort of uh uh
journalistic because a lot of the stuff
I don't do undercover work I'm talking
to a source they have documents and I'm
interviewing almost like a mini
documentary podcast oh man that's
awesome weekly bye week I'm looking
forward to seeing it dude great to see
you again I'm Ian Crossland catch you
guys later
and I'm search.com that was uh quite the
conversation I'm excited for the after
show if everyone is going to call in
again I'm at surge.com on Twitter let's
go to it we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out